how old are you I'm 33. [__] kid oh
yeah wait how are you today I'm 42 and
guess what I'm a [__] kid too I'll
tell you what you're gonna be [__]
doing this for another 60 years I mean
can you imagine being 90 though hell
yeah I can I'm gonna be a [__]
gangster I'm gonna make my best [__]
investment at 90. you [__] young
[__] I'm 90 worth 7 billion and I
still [__] got it at 90 I'm just
gonna be like dude let's let's let's we
can I'm good what we're going to do best
work 90-100 I think that's 100 shut up
I'm dead serious I think I'm momentum
what do you love the most the hustle the
game the music out of all of it honestly
if you love The Challenge there's a
better chance that you're gonna still be
doing it because your town is to walk at
that point